salut comment allez-vous moi ça va
extrêmement bien et ça allait moins bien
dans quelques minutes pourquoi parce
qu'on va jouer un jeu d'horreur il
s'appelle home sweet home
bon vous savez dire maison suite ça veut
dire mignon sauf que la maison va pas
être mignonne la bousculade dans c'est
un jeu taïwanais voilà sa soeur la focus
sur ce jeu ce parti alors ce qui suit
avec ce jeu c'est quoi c'est qu'il est
extrêmement beau parce que sonnera
l'engine écosse extrêmement bon on fait
extrêmement kaka culotte ses causes
louis qui sait que ce bruit c'est
l'autre côté elle je trouve pas dans ma
la porte mais faut il y aller
ok on est bien c'est quoi ce bruit assez
la radio times higher blanc vraie taille
à chaque fois je suis ce coup là mais
c'est vrai il ya vraiment eu un bruit
robin vient d'où vient de là je peux
ouvrir c'est verrouillé
ça met en confiance les bonnes clés à
balard oui du coup j'ai une clé je peux
utiliser dans la part je suppose le
youth key ça s'est bien fait on est bien
là oh [ __ ] c'est là qu'on va voir
et c'est sur c'est obligé ouais autres
écrits puis mec très très très creepy de
sap à venir derrière je me demande où ça
va arriver en premier en fait un peu
trop libre au québec où je descends tu
m'entends tu vas entendre il fait du
lait au mois d'août aux phoques
oui attendant la sema possible non
normand t'as pas eu le temps total ont
dépassé encore bon on est arrivé à 8h et
outré et franchement elle est bon c'est
comme ça ils m'énervent aller en avant
ça on arrête de way of make you [ __ ]
de sang et une traînée par terre
faut que je vais la traîner ça ne se
trouve pas dans ce jeu
ayew
y apprennent beaucoup avec cet homme
très bas des questions reviennent pas
capable je vais dans je referme à 15-15
à la casse et on passe maintenant
alors d'içi sadc voilà pital rodin dont
elle est repartie dans son sort très
bien je peux passer aussi dans le
portail ou pas un mode docteur strange
d'un coup elle m'apprend à faire des
portails au bafa des portails de sang je
veux ça m'intéresse pas tellement
ouaip on va faire le tour pas de souci
iphoto là il faut trouver un truc pour
le couper de quoi avoir sauté là dedans
une corde
oui tu paries ça va être une tête une
tête coupée ah non c'est bon c'est une
pince [ __ ] c'est rare qu'on trouve ce
qu'on veut wei toi et toi toi ya faute
je confie tabac arrivée annoncée bon et
j'espère apporter pour faire peur je
peux indiquer pour rien mon gars allez
on a coupé de façon peut passer au
[ __ ] les mecs quand ils font le mixage
audio du jeu ils disent allez tout ce
qui fait peur tu mets à plus d'un
décibel coach boualem madagascar frud
quoi c'est quoi qui hantent et
maintenant c'est un gobelet quoi il ça
fait quoi tu es un trio bas le talent
toujours le talent on va l'appeler
achille talon d'achille alors tout va
être fermé sauf bien sûr la porte où
elle est allée et moi je parle pourquoi
pour m'assurer que je suis un con je
vais vendre barré est pas allé dans
l'aréna foot ah voilà une chambre avec
une porte derrière home est donc me
faire douter sérieusement faire dans les
choses pour de vrai
ah le talon on l'a vu le coup je ne
devrais pas être là et bien vraiment
être là qu'est ce qui va se passer bah
je vais perdre 1 milliard d'abonnés
pourquoi un million de crise cardiaque
aucun peuple et bloquent la route il
faut trouver une sorte de marteau
ici à quoi des clous qui ce qu'il a fait
à barbiche c'est très bien ça elles vont
me dit ça me plait énormément bon allez
on se casse on y va allez allez ça
dégage les planches
voilà comme ça je peux passer c'est là
sa fin de la démo c'est ça à un [ __ ]
le pire couloir je pense pas que oui je
sais c'est possible de tout récent des
couloirs pire que ce doigt en classe je
vois rien à ces [ __ ] est mexicaine de
cours de 6 ans rampante et il adore
faire ça dans les jeux asiatiques
d'europe c deja c deja madame il faut
arrêter il faut hâter à copier lp
pourquoi tu pleures tu es fait qu'elle
perce d'affermage de venir dès que le
manga déjà quand tu vomis des patchs et
toi 4 heures du matin après une soirée
tu es tu as mal mon gars des clous
oh là [ __ ] elle est là elle est là
j'entends marché est l'ami de talent ou
alcon au [ __ ] elle est passée devant
nous elle est allée à gauche on est bon
on est libre mais qu à gages un circuit
à [ __ ] faut trouver un fusible c'est
sa photo un fusible pour avoir accès à
l'ascenseur si j'ai cru que elle arrive
alive à l'arrêt c'est parfait elles sont
tous partagent passe devant je vais
faire un check alors vers la porte du
coup ça du coup j'ai accès à cette salle
oh c'est quoi ça assez pour se pencher
ok c'est quand tes cachets voilà [ __ ]
dans la grosse [ __ ] ses cachets mais n'a
pas suffi pas suivi elle est où je la
vois pas où est tu es là elle veut pas
bouger sa vie c'est ça à ok faut que
l'acompte en eau la [ __ ] voilà put voit
la pub
bah
super bien je suivrai pour deux
elle n'a pas perdu de temps à autre de
quel sens mal ça veut rien dire nous a
pas vus elle n'a pas vu ses shows mec
c'est mon pel sommes prêts à les salir
les chiottes ou c'est un piège c'est un
guet-apens et connaît des journaux mais
je m'en bats les couilles choqué news
bon bah écoutes je sortir son rangement
toujours un sens je le lirai quand je
serai chez moi elles roulent mais qu
elle rôde non pour de vrai instinct
rôdeur aller où elle allait dans le mur
à droite j rien un [ __ ] je passe sur
un jeu passera à voilà je suis pas je
suis pas là même elle comme devant les
chiens mais t'as pas tu vas faire que
deux complexes dans les chiottes ma
[ __ ] je peux courir à bois je crois
mais en fait ce choix il faut courir et
basilic sa mère déclare un public duquel
démocratie tu as mumbai quick ou très
mauvais choix de jeu ça quant à la gorge
sensible à ok c'est bon train mais ce
qui va être content ok on est passé au
[ __ ] donc là logiquement vers le
fusible c'est sa vie c'est maintenant
c'est maintenant c'est maintenant c'est
non c'est non non je peux me lever vous
a pas trop beau eu dans ce match que
nous venons [ __ ] [ __ ] on achète
qu'on a on à chaque combat auquel j'ai
vu
tu as emballé elle va m'avoir d'avancé
sur le mentionne là mais non non mais
c'est dur a maintenant assez moyen
checkpoint bon elle est où là je peux
l'avoir terrain surtout auquel l ariège
la voile s'approche elle met ses petites
crocs et elle va nous croquer dans le
sahara est ok ces moments là non je suis
à l'abri si c'est bon elle est là bas on
peut passer on dégage d'ici mon pote
voilà on va vivre un coup est parti
filmer son petit fusible ça passe au
vert on l'appelle la politique assez
très vite se casser allez allez allez on
est bons trucs années passées on est
passé et là on appuie sur mais n'en
oublie pas a été fait qu'elle a au vite
ouvre toi
depeche mode et buteur face à sastre à
petit chèque comme tyler hawkins partie
aux [ __ ] à tout ce qui bouge est
vénère le sens a ralenti ok j'ai compris
c'est au tour de mario kart finalement
oui oui allez on s'en fie aux précaires
gilles hugot
merci d'avoir joué à la démo le jeu
sortira en entier le deuxième trimestre
2010 cette [ __ ] bah ouais c'est sûr ce
postiche d'europe top on fait des jeux
offs et des tueries savez mécanique
doubt là c'est que le jeu a l'air
fois-là l'espèce de soa simulator ya un
[ __ ] de monde tu sais qui peut de
choper comme ça est planté comme ça il
est pas là pour toi pierre feuille
ciseaux ce soit ce que je veux dire et
tu dois l'esquivé pour atteindre la
sortie mais tu sais très bien que la
sortie va se boucher comme le
périphérique extérieur de paris à 18
heures c'est un [ __ ] je n'étais pas
assez donc ça vous a plus peur sont très
vite dans une prochaine pour être un
petit peu de fun parce que là la vois ça
un bug effet sonore de qualité elle tout
de même une autre partie vous bien je
vais me refaire un thé à jan